los hechos pero como tú bien ha relatado
antes empiezan con un acto reprobable
que es cortar la cabeza a un profesor
por explicar algo en clase sea por
precisamente por no tener porque es
libertad de expresión luego hemos visto
como a chrome se puso firme contra esto
de este ataque cuando le cortaron la
cabeza al profesor y que rápidamente los
radicales islamistas pues empezaron a
lanzar su mensaje su mensaje básicamente
es atacar a francia atacar a francia
como a la cual la cocina como los
líderes digamos de los de los infieles
no y ellos lo que claramente lo que
intentan imponer no sólo en francia sin
europa es esa conquista silenciosa por
miedo medio del miedo y por medio de
esas actuaciones en violentas lo que
tiene que hacer europa y en este caso
francia es actuar con contundencia nos
deja ser primeriza porque esto va a
seguir ellos saben qué
por estos actos crean una situación
mediática y en la opinión pública que
eran un terror muy amplio y francia- lo
que tiene que hacer es tomar todas las
medidas para intentar acabar con este
tipo de ataques y sobre todo acabar con
esas mezquitas con esos
personajes que incitan el odio y que
llevan a multitud de musulmanes a
realizar actos pues que lógicamente
están fuera de la ley y que no son de
acorde que creamos con la convivencia
accidental